more hospital beds but no more hospital
staff
it isn't unusual for the health service
to struggle over the winter months but
pressure from the pandemic once again is
unrelenting
more than 20 nhs trusts across the
country have now declared a critical
incident and in greater manchester
non-urgent surgeries and appointments
have come to a halt
the iron colleagues are extremely sorry
for the very difficult decision that we
had to make that hasn't been made
lightly
what we want to do is try and make sure
we minimize the impact as much as
possible
by as soon as this is over returning to
try and recovering
through our non-urgent work in order to
get those operations done it's staff
shortages from coveted infections and
isolation which is driving this current
crisis in the nhs
royal bolton's a e department was today
working with less than half of its
doctors
nurses now doing overtime as their
colleagues call in sick health bosses
are monitoring the situation carefully
and anxiously the staffing crisis across
greater manchester is two to three times
the normal level and whilst for now they
are holding on
the days ahead are difficult to predict
it's
deteriorated full of arthritis for steve
a long suffering patient this decision
in greater manchester is a devastating
blow a much needed operation on his knee
has been pushed back once again
demoralizing rio because
i've um i really wanted it done this
this year so i can get back working
before retirement age it's all in
mobility and it's pain at night pain in
the day
it's constant sometimes it's never
ending
just keep waiting
just like everyone else across the
region's hospitals there are now in
excess of 1200 patients with covid19 in
some more than one in five people have
the virus the pm's plan to ride out this
wave doesn't sit well here that isn't a
phrase that we would we would use from
our perspective here in greater
manchester um
because i don't think it does justice to
the position in our public services and
the pressure
that
staff working in the nhs in social care
and on the front line and other services
i don't think it reflects the position
that they're in
but pressures are being felt across the
nation northeast ambulance service today
asking people with chest pains to take a
taxi to hospital rather than wait for a
paramedic
all signs of the desperate situation our
health system is in one which is already
playing catch-up and with a warning of
challenging weeks ahead that problem may
only deepen intimate rasheed sky news
bolton